is it just me or are there other people
here that are a little bit disappointed
with democracy so let's look at a few
numbers if we look across the world
the median turnout in presidential
elections over the last 30 years has
been just 67% now we go to Europe and we
look at people that participated in EU
parliamentary elections the median
turnout in those elections is just 42
percent now let's go to New York and
let's see how many people voted in the
last election for mayor and we'll find
that only 24% of people showed up to
vote what that means is that if friends
were still running Joey and maybe Phoebe
who had shown up to vote and you cannot
blame them because people are tired of
politicians and people are tired of
other people using the data that they
have generated to communicate with their
friends and family to target political
propaganda at them but the thing about
this is that this is not new nowadays
people use likes to target propaganda at
you before they use your zip code or
your gender or your age because the idea
of targeting people with propaganda for
political purpose is as old as politics
and the reason why that idea is there is
because democracy has a basic
vulnerability this is the idea of a
representative in principle democracy is
the ability of people to exert power but
in practice we have to delegate that
power to a representative that can exert
that power for us that representative is
a bottleneck or a weak spot it is the
place that you want to target if you
wanna attack democracy because you can
capture democracy by either capturing
that representative or capturing the way
that people choose it so the big
question is is this the end of history
is this the best that we can do or
actually are there alternatives some
people have been thinking about
alternatives and one of the ideas that
is out there is the idea of direct
democracy this is the idea of bypassing
politicians completely and having people
both directly on issues having people
vote directly on bills but this idea is
naive because there's too many things
that we will need to choose if you look
at the 114th US Congress you would have
seen that the House of Representative
considered more than 6,000 bills the
Senate considered more than 3000 bills
and they approve more than 300 laws
those would be many decisions that each
person would have to make a week on
topics that they know little about
so there's a big cognitive bandwidth
problem if we're gonna try to think
about direct democracy as a viable
alternative so some people think about
the idea of liquid democracy or fluid
democracy which is idea that you endorse
your political power to someone that can
endorse it to someone else and
eventually you create a large follower
network in which at the end there's a
few people that are making decisions on
behalf of all of their followers and
their followers but this idea also
doesn't solve the problem of the
counting the bandwidth and to be honest
it's also quite similar to the idea of
having a representative so what I'm
going to do today is I'm going to be a
little bit provocative and I'm gonna ask
you well what if instead of trying to
bypass politicians we try to automate
them
the idea of automation is not new it is
started more than 300 years ago when
French Weaver's decided to automate the
loom
the winner of that industrial world was
yourself Mary Shekhar
he was a French Weaver and merchant that
married the loom with the steam engine
to create all tournaments and in those
autonomous looms he gained control he
could now make fabrics that were more
complex are more sophisticated than the
ones that were able to do by hand but
also by winning that industrial war he
laid out what has become the blueprint
of automation the way that we automate
things for the last 300 years has always
been the same we first identify a need
then we create a tool to satisfy that
need
like the loom in this case and then we
study how people used that tool to
automate that user that's how we came
from the mechanical room to the
autonomous loom and that took us a
thousand years now it's taking us only a
hundred years to use the same script to
automate the car but the thing is that
this time around automation is kind of
for real this is a video that a
colleague of mine from Toshiba shared
with me that shows the factory that
manufactures solid-state drives the
entire factory is a robot there are no
humans in that Factory and the robots
are soon to leave the factories and
become part of our world become part of
our workforce so what I'm doing my day
job is actually create tools that
integrate data for entire countries so
that we can ultimately have the
foundations that we need for a future in
which we need to manage also those
machines but today I'm not here to talk
to you about these tools that integrate
data for countries but I'm here to talk
to you about another idea that may help
us think about how to use artificial
intelligence in democracy because the
tools that I build are designed for
executive decisions these are decisions
that can be cast in some sort of term of
objectivity public investment decisions
but there are decisions that are
legislated
and these decisions that our legislative
require communication among people that
have different points of view require
participation require debate require
deliberation and for a long time we have
thought that well what we need to
improve democracy it's actually more
communication so all of the technologies
that we have advanced in the context of
democracy where there are newspapers or
whether it is social media have tried to
provide us with more communication but
we've been down that rabbit hole and we
know that that's not what's going to
solve the problem because it's not a
communication problem it's a cognitive
bandwidth problem so if the problem is
one of cognitive bandwidth well added
more communication to people is not
going to be what's going to solve it
what we're gonna need instead is to have
other technologies that help us deal
with some of the communication that we
are overloaded with think of like a
little Avatar a software agent a digital
Jiminy Cricket that basically is able to
answer things on your behalf
and if we would have that technology
we'll be able to offload some of the
communication and help maybe make better
decisions or decisions at a larger scale
and the thing is that the idea of
software agents also is not new we
already use them all the time we use
software agents to choose the way that
we're going to drive to a certain
location the music that we're going to
listen to or to get suggestions for the
next books that we should read so there
is an obvious idea in the 21st century
that was as obvious as the idea of
putting together a steam engine with a
loom at the time of jacquard and that
idea is combining direct democracy with
software agents imagine for a second a
world in which instead of having a
representative that represents you and
millions of other peoples you can have a
representative that represents only you
with your new ins political views that
weird combination of libertarian and
liberal and maybe a little bit
conservative on some issues some may be
very progressive on others
politicians nowadays are packages and
they're full of compromises but you
might have someone that can
and only you if you are willing to give
up the idea that that representative is
a human if that represented is a
software agent we could have a Senate
that has as many senators as we have
citizens and those senators are going to
be able to read every bill and they're
gonna be able to vote on each one of
them so there's an obvious idea that
maybe we want to consider but I
understand that in this day and age this
idea might be quite scary
in fact thinking of a robot coming from
the future to help us run our
governments sounds terrifying but we've
been there before and actually he was
quite a nice guy so how would the
jacquard loom version of this idea would
look like so it would be a very simple
system imagine a system that you log in
and you create your avatar and then
you're going to start training your
avatar so you can provide your avatar
with your reading habits or connect it
to your social media or you can connect
it you know to other data for example by
taking psychological test and the nice
thing about this is that there's no
deception you are not providing data to
communicate with your friends and family
that then gets used you know in a
political system you are providing data
to a system that is designed to be used
to make political decisions on your
behalf then you take that data and you
choose you know a training algorithm
this is an open marketplace in which
different people can submit different
algorithms to predict you know how
you're going to vote based on the data
and you have provided and the system is
open so nobody controls the algorithms
there are girls that become more popular
other ones that become less popular and
eventually you can audit the system you
can see how your avatar is working and
if you like it you can leave it on
autopilot if you want to be a little
more controlling you can actually choose
that they ask you every time that
they're going to make a decision or you
can be anywhere in between one of the
reasons why we use democracy is so
little
maybe because democracy has a very bad
user interface and if we improve the
user interface of democracy we might be
able to use it more of course there's a
lot of questions that you might have
well how do you train these avatars how
do
you keep the data secure how do you keep
the systems distributed and auditable
how about my grandma that is 80 years
old and doesn't know how to use the
internet trust me
I've heard them all so when you think
about an idea like this you have to
beware of pessimists because they're
known to have a problem for every
solution so when I want to invite you is
to think about the bigger ideas the
questions that I just showed you are
little ideas because they're questions
about how this would not work the big
ideas and ideas of what else can you do
with this is this would happen to work
and one of those ideas is well who
writes the laws in the beginning we
could have the avatars that we already
have both in our laws that are written
by the Senators or politicians that we
already have but if this were to work
you could write an algorithm that could
try to write a law that would get a
certain percentage of approval and you
could reverse the process now you might
think that this idea is ludicrous and we
should not do it but you cannot deny
that it's an idea that is only possible
in a world in which direct democracy and
software agents are a viable form of
participation so how do we start a
revolution and we don't start this
revolution with picket fences or
protests or by demanding our current
politicians to be changed into robots
that's not going to work
this is much more simple much slower and
much more humble
we started revolution by creating simple
systems like this in grad schools in
libraries in nonprofits and we try to
figure out all of those little questions
and those little problems that we're
gonna have to figure out to make this
idea something viable to make this idea
something that we can trust and as we
create those systems that have a hundred
people a thousand people 100,000 people
voting in ways that are not politically
binding we're gonna develop trust in
this idea the world is gonna change and
those that are as little as my daughter
is right now are gonna grow up and by
the time that my daughter is my age
maybe this idea that I know is today
very crazy
might not be crazy to her and to her
friends and at that point we will be at
the end of our history but they will be
at the beginning of theirs
thank you
[Applause]